all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Avengers versus
X-Men versus eternals Judgment Day and
The Return of the Phoenix Force which I
am ridiculously excited about by the way
yes the new trailer for Ant-Man and wasp
quantumania came out yes we'll be doing
it here on Comics explain instead of
geek culture explained because I don't
want to burn myself out and that video
will be here later on this week so
having said that this is ridiculously
cool and there's a lot of history that
goes into this right so we're gonna have
a field day with this story because it's
absolutely amazing so one of the things
to remember is that when you have the
kind of unity Squad which is basically
what this is Iron Man Jean Gray you do
have like Logan and like some of the
other eternals who are here this is
their second attempt at a strike force
and this is what we talked about before
the first attempt at the strike force
was to basically hit like what was
essentially the kill switch for the
progenitor Celestial this one is more of
trying to find a way to destroy it from
the inside out now initially they
thought they could be sneaky and get on
board but the funny thing about this and
this just shows the level of power the
progenitor Celestial has and its lack of
of concern is that even when they're
inside of it it's still testing them so
the last video that we did focused on
the test of Iron Man of Tony Stark
testing his character to see whether or
not he's worthy of surviving with Jean
Gray it's much the same way here the
funny thing about this is that when this
goes down as they're making their way to
the heart of the celestial so to speak
that Jean Gray is able to help them deal
with some of the forces to a degree but
then her test begins and she suddenly
yanked back to the Xavier school for
gifted youngsters now this is one of the
cool moments and there is a little bit
of History here so for those guys who
are unfamiliar with Jean Gray when she
initially appeared in Marvel Comics
she'd literally showed up in X-Men issue
number one and was kind of our eyes and
ears as the reader meaning she was given
a tour of the entire grounds by
Professor Xavier she was told what the
X-Men were what their purpose is why
they do what they do that kind of thing
but there was a story there was written
later on by Chris Claremont in Bizarre
Adventures Issue Number 27 and what this
did is it actually told us Xavier had
been watching Jean Gray for quite some
time that this was actually included
later on in the X-Men Origins Gene gray
one shot but the way the story was
originally written is that when Jean
Gray was a little girl her friend Annie
died and when that happened she kind of
sent out this sort of telepathic shock
wave like an SOS right like a telepathic
scream of Anguish if you want to call it
that Xavier picked up on it but so did
the Phoenix force and both of them
basically watched Jean Gray the Phoenix
Force watched her knowing that Jean Gray
was the kind of person who would
eventually become the host of The
Phoenix and Xavier watched her because
he realized how powerful she was
telepathically and telekinetically and
so this is why she was originally
brought on the X-Men team now unlike
what we saw in the Iron Man one shot
that we covered in the last video where
it's strictly confined in the mind of
Iron Man this one actually shows us what
other people are doing right so it's
kind of a little bit of a jump back and
forth but the reality is for the most
part they come to the consensus this is
Jean Gray's test Jean Gray has to be the
one to endure it but there will be a
kind of stepping in that does take place
but the celestial continuing to prod her
mind showing her these parts of herself
and force her to confront these aspects
that she had largely wanted to get rid
of it basically takes her mind to the
quiet Council when they were initially
trying to decide what they were going to
do with the progenitor Celestial and the
reality here is the discussion as it
took place was a discussion of okay
what's best for the world how do we
handle this so on and so forth the real
meat and potatoes of this discussion was
that the quiet Council didn't really
care how their actions impacted normal
mutants who were out there or even just
regular human beings because ever since
the process of Resurrection was Mastered
by mutants they've become very Cavalier
with the lives of mutants and this
manifests in the way in which the
discussion is presented to Jean Gray if
we succeed it will almost certainly kill
Untold millions of distinctly
unfashionable dressed humans but perhaps
it's still a worthwhile use of our time
of course we won't tell the foot
soldiers no need for the little people
to know anybody object please raise your
hands and it's one of those things where
it's like Jean Gray you have blood on
your hands right and that's the crazy
thing is because her response is no I I
left the quiet Council because I wanted
to be a hero I wanted to actually do
things that could make a difference but
the response of the progenitor's
celestial here is that may be but you
left the position they gave you the best
chance of doing so the best thing you
could have done was stay on the quiet
Council they're the ones who make the
decisions leaving a position of power
under the guise of wanting to affect
actual change that's a that's a lie it's
a lie you tell yourself and it's a lie
you tell the world what you did Jean
Gray was an act of hubris you wanted to
be the hero so you cooked up some kind
of an excuse that made you feel better
and now you get to go out there and be
the hero and so she initially again
tries to reject this idea of Mind Games
and so there actually comes a point when
Mr Sinister brings himself and Wolverine
into his mind or into the mind of the
celestial in the mind of Jean Gray and
what it does is it allows the celestial
to scan the two of them as what are
basically character Witnesses and that's
the cool thing is because initially it
goes for sinister and it's like tell me
what you think about Jean Gray honest
lastly and Sinister doesn't really love
Jean Gray and never really has when it
came to Sinister as a person his
fascination with Jean Gray was based on
her genealogy remember the old school
basis behind Sinister despite the fact
that it's changed in more recent years
has been the Sinister new or came to the
realization that if Jean Gray and
cyclops were to ever have a child that
child would be Godly in terms of power
one of the things he says here is he
says I cloned Jean Gray and I couldn't
clone Gene gray I made something else
several times some better than others
but none annoyingly better than her what
he's referencing here is when he created
Madeleine Pryor Madeleine Pryor was the
attempt by Sinister to clone Gene gray
the problem he ran into is he could
clone Gene gray in terms of her physical
appearance but he couldn't clone the
essence of what made her who she was or
even her powers that's why Madeline
Pryor was never on the same level as
Gene and that's why she was considered a
failed experiment by Sinister when it
comes to Wolverine it's much simpler
than that Wolverine loves Gene in Gray
so he will never speak ill of her
because he doesn't see her in any way
but a positive light and that's when
everything shifts and you get this
amazing moment in this comic so at that
point the celestial whisks away Sinister
in Wolverine and is like enough he says
their Insight helps one who loves you
and one who envies you yes I think I
understand now or at least I understand
enough I met your husband Cyclops he
implied that I should be scared of you a
man who loves you thinks that something
like me should be afraid of you he is
married to something that on a
fundamental level scares the hell out of
him such bravery of course I passed him
he sleeps in the lair of a red dragon
and I think he's right I think you are
like me now this is where things get
really awesome and this is where the
kind of where the celestial sort of
looks at Jean Gray and says we're
similar but we're starkly different at
the same time he says and for the love
you share and provoke that is the part I
cannot get past yes I am destroying a
world but you destroyed a world for no
reason at all and her response is dark
Phoenix was not me it was but it's it's
really complicated now to explain this
because I imagine a lot of you guys who
aren't really familiar with the X-Men
Mythos are a little confused by this
when Chris Claremont took over writing
of the X-Men back in the 70s his idea
was that Jean Gray was a character that
had been underutilized in every capacity
but he also wanted to move past the
original X-Men team and basically create
a team of his own hence the reason why
he built on Lynn wines giant-sized X-Men
run but the idea behind this is that he
wanted to elevate Jean Gray to basically
make up for how her character had been
treated and then ride her out in a blaze
of glory so he gave us the Phoenix and
the dark Phoenix sagas right Jean Gray
attains This Godly level of power she
ends up going insane and then she
sacrifices her life for the good of
everybody the problem was that Jean Gray
was so ridiculously popular during that
time that Marvel editorial made Chris
Claremont bring Jean Gray back but what
Marvel did is they said that when Jean
Gray and initially got the Phoenix force
that what the Phoenix had done was
actually copy Jean Gray and the real
Gene gray was just sitting in the bottom
of Jamaica Bay she was ultimately
discovered by The Fantastic Four and the
Fantastic Four brought her to the X-Men
and then what Marvel established was
that when the Phoenix had all that power
it was actually the Phoenix Force
pretending to be Jean Gray when the
Phoenix went nuts and became the dark
Phoenix that it was never actually Jean
Gray it was just the Phoenix had lost
its mind and looked like Jean Gray it
was basically a way to exonerate Gene of
everything that she'd done it still
holds true Marvel's never gone back and
changed that and they probably never
will but that's what she's referencing
here now the funny thing is the
celestial responds and saying yes
sometimes you are a Saint Jean Gray but
at other times you are a violent bully
and above all once you destroyed a world
and that's the thing like she initially
says and I'm going to destroy you and
the celestial says and again violence
now she responds of course in making the
best argument she can she says listen
last month alone I went to a casino
where countless worlds Fates were were
being wagered on I saved Untold numbers
of Worlds if I were keeping score I'm in
the block and the response of the
celestial is yes you went to this place
where people were betting on ways to
destroy worlds but your friends would
have saved those worlds without you and
they have not burned at all so basically
the response he's making here is you
cannot use that as some kind of a
justification for all the terrible
things you've done and said look I
destroyed an entire world I killed
countless villains which in reality she
destroyed an entire star system is
actually what happened but like she's
like you know I yes I killed all those
terrible people but look at this great
thing I did here I did this great thing
here and that should atone for it that
should make up for it I've tried to be a
hero all this time and the response of
the celestial is no that's not how this
works she asked the question like what
can I possibly do to make up for this
and the response to the celestial is you
can never make up for this Jean Gray you
are the Phoenix now and forever and the
Phoenix effectively rebonds itself or
seemingly rebounds itself with Gene
great in the process but literally what
this means is that Jean Gray when
seemingly she was the dark Phoenix what
this is Marvel doing is seemingly coming
back and saying actually that was Jean
Gray right we're undoing all that stuff
where it wasn't actually her that was
Jean Gray she was the dark Phoenix it
wasn't the dark Phoenix replacing her or
copying her that was Jean Gray and she
did destroy that entire star system she
did kill all those people there's
nothing you can do to atone for and the
actions of Jean Gray over the course of
all this time after the events of the
Phoenix and the dark Phoenix Saga was
never about her trying to atone for what
she'd done it was never about her saying
okay yes I did that and I'm trying to
make amends right because given the
various Heights of her power she could
have brought those worlds back she could
have returned those worlds during like
Phoenix M song Phoenix War song right
when she was at the peak of her power
when she was in the white hot room the
white Phoenix of the crown she could
have fixed her past mistakes but the
reality is she didn't because it was
never about atoning for her action it
was never about making up for her past
misdeeds she like so many of us out here
in the real world it was just about
making herself feel better about what
she'd done it was selfish that's all it
was it was I did a really bad thing and
I want to feel better about the fact
that I did it so I'm gonna do a lot of
good things and it'll even out right
like the scales will be tipped maybe in
my favor but at the very least they'll
be balanced right like you know it won't
be as bad or it won't be so terrible
that's literally what it was what this
this progenitor Celestial is forcing her
to face is the fact that it doesn't work
that way just because you did a terrible
thing does not mean you get to do an
equally good thing and everything
balances out and All Is Forgiven and the
day is saved the fact and the reality is
you did a terrible thing you did a
horrible thing it's great that you did a
great thing to try to make up for it but
it doesn't change the fact that you did
that horrible thing you cannot atone for
this you cannot make up for this you
can't rinse this blood off your hands
and all the actions that you've engaged
in since then have just been selfish
actions so again it's really amazing
here because once Jean Gray snaps back
and she's back to her normal self she
actually kind of swears out this blood
Feud on the progenitor Celestial and
what's so ironic about this is she
learned nothing from that test she
learned absolutely nothing at all the
basis of the test was to teach her you
have to learn to make up for the things
that you've done what she's doing here
is she's saying I'm going to destroy you
in effect the progenitor Celestial
confronted her with the reality she
doesn't like and like anybody on Twitter
or Reddit or Facebook or just social
media in general she's choosing to
reject the reality of the situation that
she's in and replace it with one that
she finds more agreeable so she
basically lashes out at the celestial
and is like I'm going to destroy you in
your entirety yes I am the Phoenix and
yes I Harbor the power of the Phoenix
and by hell or high water I will destroy
you right I will end you in your
entirety so it's an amazing comic with a
really kind of sad ending for the
character of Gene because again she
learns absolutely no nothing but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace